the fighting is paused in the middle
east
but things are getting pretty heated
here at home a disturbing wave of hate
aimed at jewish americans
like this next scene in new york city
where pro-palestinian protesters
clash with pro-israeli activists
and in los angeles an suv with a
palestinian flag
was caught on camera chasing down a
jewish man
the victim says he thought he was going
to die and the perpetrators were yelling
alu akbar
republican senator ted cruz blaming the
rhetoric of far left democrats for
what's happening
it's reprehensible the anti-semitic
violence we're seeing and and we've been
seeing a rise of anti-semitic violence
both in america and
in europe and and unfortunately it is
encouraged it's encouraged by radical
islamic terrorists it's also encouraged
by the angry left the the far left
that that regularly trafficks in
anti-israel rhetoric
anti-semitic rhetoric
jesse uh this kind of partisan violence
here at home is just so upsetting
i mean to blame jewish people for
israeli policy
that's wrong it's just like blaming
chinese people for
china's covet policies what would you
suggest
political leaders do to calm people down
here
well the squad is disparaging israel
as an apartheid state they might want to
dial back language like that
because if this were the other way
around and trump said something and
somewhat did something like this
they'd probably draw up an impeachment
article
but i mean i'm looking at this on the
screen juan i mean is this the mideast
or is this midtown this is
just right across the street from fox
this is in the diamond district i got my
engagement ring right
there i hope my jeweler is okay but i
hope everyone's okay
this is this did not look to me they're
calling it a
firework that looked like commercial
grade that was not a little m80 right
there
and it was premeditated this these
aren't people getting carried away at a
bar
this is a textbook hate crime
this was people getting into a truck and
driving to the diamond district
with the intention of causing violence
and
if you adjust for population
anti-semitism in america is the biggest
hate crime jews make up just a smidgen
of the u.s population yet they're more
targeted for hate crimes in
any other group blacks hispanics asians
and the media doesn't talk about it the
media looks at video of
black americans attacking asian
americans they don't talk about that
either
but if you're going to cover hate crimes
you have to treat them fairly and you
don't have to wait and see
the race or ethnicity of the perp or the
victim
you just have to call balls and strikes
and it makes people
very angry that hate crimes in this
country are suppressed
in order to protect a political group
and that's what's happening here i think
everybody needs to chill
we don't want this country to look like
gaza we don't want factions
attacking each other in the streets i
can't even believe i'm seeing this
and this is right outside where we're
broadcasting right now it makes me sick
kennedy uh we're also seeing this happen
inside
israel and i again it's just so
disturbing you know
i don't know if everyone realizes it but
20 of the israeli population
is arab and for the first time you have
now widespread outbreaks of violence
between
arabs and israelis what do you
see happening there how can that calm
down or is that you just think it's
going to get worse
i i think it's going to get worse before
it gets better because we don't really
have
a solid diplomatic solution on the table
i thought the abraham accords were a
really really good place
to start and anytime your focal point
is economic prosperity and cooperation
uh you're going to end in a much better
place
and and that's obviously what we want to
see we want a de-escalation you know we
want a ceasefire we want people to be
safe we want them to thrive
and hamas is not the palestinian people
we have to separate that
uh jewish people in america you're
absolutely right one they are not the
israeli government
there's no rationality for this type of
violence and you're seeing it in new
york
where there is a concentration of jewish
vendors on 47th street in the diamond
district
and they were a magnet yesterday for
violence
one man said that he was standing there
speaking
in hebrew and a man came up was
listening to them ran into the crowd
came back
with 10 guys surrounded them and
attacked them
you know one guy had the uh flag of
israel torn out of his hands he turned
around
to grab it back from the guy he got
punched in the stomach 26 people were
arrested yesterday
we were in the studio right upstairs
where i broadcast my fox business show
and as we were getting ready for the
show we could see people running around
people were terrified because
you don't know if that's an m80 you
don't know if it's an explosive you
don't know if it's a gun
and it's you don't know how much more
it's going to escalate
we cannot live like this it has to get
better
and yes some of those anti-semitic
lawmakers they really have to tone it
down
so jillian what's next in terms of on
the ground
in the middle east uh we know that the
ceasefire
is very tentative uh everyone's anxious
that to see
that it does hold do you think is any
hope that we can get back to like the
oslo accords and talk of a two-state
solution
no um to put a fine point on it as they
answer that question i want to just make
a comment
juan if i may about what's happening
here in u.s streets watching this
footage the last few minutes it's like
the rest of america is finally now
waking up to the reality that american
jews have been ringing alarm bells about
for years now that anti-semitism is
alive
it's more virulent than ever before
inside the united states
and it's spreading like wildfire there
was this pew survey they do these
periodically it came out a few days ago
that found three quarters of american
jews think there's more anti-semitism in
the united states today than five years
ago and more than
half of american jews 53 percent say
that as a jewish person in the united
states they feel personally
less safe now than they did five years
ago this speaks
to the timeline here this is not a new
problem
this is the first time we're maybe
seeing anti-semitic violence erupt
in broad daylight in the middle of times
square for a long time but this problem
has been
bubbling and simmering and now exploding
it's taken a long time to get here i
also want to say that i think
doling out blame to one or the other
political parties in this country does a
disservice to the underlying issue which
is
anti-semitism i don't think you can pin
this squarely on the squad though their
rhetoric isn't helpful
this started a long time before alan
o'mar or alexandria ocasio-cortez were
in congress
it's going to continue on it's a stain
on the country
frankly all right so
let me ask katie then just give us a
quick sense if you could katie about
what you think comes next in the middle
east
where is this going is there any hopeful
ray of light here
yeah so i'll get to that in just a
second first i want to say you know
we've heard that this is that the jewish
americans are not responsible for what
uh is going on in israel and that is
true but because
the palestinians both in uh israel and
palestinian americans here believe that
if jews fight back
and defend themselves that they will not
be held accountable
for attacking them but rather the jews
will be threatened and said that
you need to cease fire and you need to
make sure that you
act with restraint they think now that
they're going to be
able to get away with this kind of
violent activity whether it's in
la in new york in florida because
there's no accountability
for these violent attacks on jews the
issue is anti-semitism the
issue is not israel israel israelis
or american jews it's anti-semitism in
general as far as what's going to happen
in the middle east i talked to someone
who's watched the middle east
lived there worked there for many years
and they believe that a third
intifada is coming this summer and the
reason is if you look at this so-called
ceasefire which really is just
these was really the israelis defending
themselves against a terrorist
organization
uh and and preventing civilian
casualties there are thousands of
people on the temple mount today at
alaska mosque
and they are unfurling posters of
iranian
leaders and hamas flags on the temple
mount that does not bode well
for the future of what's going to happen
there in terms of any kind of peace
agreement especially when you have the
biden administration negotiating in
vienna
to infuse and take off sanctions on iran
which means
they will just have more money for
weapons uh the palestinians and the
hamas factions
in the middle east in in other factions
as well
quite frankly have no interest uh in
peace for israel and one last thing
there is a civil war brewing in the west
bank between
the palestinian authority and hamas
hamas is upset
the elections were canceled for
president mahmoud abbas
they wanted to win those elections to
take over the west bank so israel will
then be used as a scapegoat in the
middle
for those two factions of terrorism to
fight each other for credibility and
power in the middle east
so i don't see this going anywhere soon
in terms of
the middle east and also what's
happening in the united states and
jewish americans be attacked
by palestinian protesters juan one quick
thing that would help because you asked
about a solution
is if hamas was not allowed to burrow
and hide behind
civilian outposts inside israel anymore
hospitals
media outlets like we saw this week
schools that's something where the u.s
can actually make a huge difference
i think yeah i think that's right and i
think uh
you know prime minister netanyahu has
said that he really appreciates
president biden's support so far we'll
see if that continues hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else